described as the jewel in qatar's World
Cup Crown this is Lucille Stadium the
venue that will host the World Cup final
the largest of the eight World Cup
venues the stadium can host up to 80 000
fans
the amount of Steel used in the
construction of the stadium could have
built four Eiffel Towers
it's designed to replicate one of the
Region's traditional handcrafted bowls
Stadium's architect told me he hopes of
any shape will create an immersive
experience for both players and fans
[Music]
now if you're planning on watching the
world cup from home one thing that you
won't see is the nearly 150 kilometers
of cable that will be neatly hidden
under the pitch
[Music]
welcome to the VIP lounge but on Match
day you'll only be able to get in here
with an invite
this is one of the areas that's planned
to be transformed into a community Hub
featuring affordable housing shops
restaurants even medical clinics after
the World Cup
this is where the World Cup winning
coach and players will come after the
final it's the post-match press
conference room now this is the biggest
one I've ever seen it can hold around
300 journalists depending on how the
match went it will be your happy place
or one you'll want to get out of as soon
as possible
foreign
[Music]